johan ans poursuit cette chronique et on
change d'univers après de l'animation
les fatals picards faisait la musique
oui mais laurent pas très loin puisqu'on
passe de saint-cyr-l'ecole à bois d'arcy
les fatals picards se produiront sur la
scène de la bri blues samedi le 20
octobre à 21h moi je suis arrivé en 2004
le groupe il existait il existait depuis
on va dire 99 2000 mais pour de vrai sur
les sur scène depuis depuis 2001 2002
quoi c'est un groupe qui tourne et voilà
quand je suis arrivé dans le groupe ça
tournait ça commençait à tourner bien
depuis un an ou deux les fatals picards
un groupe qui conjugue humour et musique
avec des textes engagés
traversant différents styles musicaux il
s'en prend tantôt au punk tantôt au
reggae en fait il n'y a pas de style
musical particulier par rapport aux par
rapport au groupe étant et que disons
que le cahier des charges dont des
fatals picards c'est plus de la musique
humoristique donc en fait après la
musique dépendra du texte choisi il ya
des chansons un petit peu premier degré
qui voilà qui qui sont bien avec une
usine un petit peu plus rock un petit
peu plus punk d il ya des textes un
petit peu plus on va dire sensible aux
nostalgiques mais qui sous qui vont plus
avec une orchestration un peu plus
chanson française parlons-en de la
chanson française en 2007 les musiciens
représente l'hexagone au concours de
l'eurovision avec l'amour à la française
wade et toi tu es chez toi tu en mets
pas rien car tu n'en
je ne regarde
il faut dit
si les fatals picards se produiront le
20 octobre sur la scène de la bri blues
à bois d'arcy le groupe achève sa
deuxième année de tournée pour l'album
coming out avant de sortir un nouvel
opus en 2013 la scène devient une zone
test pour de nouveaux morceaux
ça y est
des photos
le terrain
non
c'est vrai que depuis quelques temps on
essaie d'incorporer dans notre
répertoire des nouvelles chansons qu'on
va sortir l'année prochaine pour voir un
petit peu quelle est la réaction du
public voir si si c'est là on va pouvoir
les exploiter scéniquement parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte au fil du temps qu'il
ya des chansons qui qui fonctionne très
bien randy ce qui est moins bien sur
scène et à l'inversé c'est pareil quoi
donc voilà ce qu'on va voir à bois
d'arcy c'est ça c'est beaucoup de
chansons de notre dernier album enfin
beaucoup de chansons des trois derniers
on va piocher un peu dans la carte war
beaucoup plus vieux mais manière un peu
plus anecdotique
et puis quelques nouvelles chansons
quelques nouveautés voilà donc on
commence à jouer donc y sont on va dire
qu'ils sont frais mais ce n'est pas
aussi car est qu'il est très content ou
punir mais demain
les fatals picards toujours plein
d'énergie mais si vous n'aimez pas les
fatals picards le week end est très
chargé